quality is important to car
manufacturers howdy has a tech day we're
interested people can visit various
departments and laboratories for an
insight into the company's quality
control efforts the first stop for
visitors focuses on fault analysis more
than ten thousand sensors measure a huge
variety of parameters in the vehicle for
demonstration purposes a metal bar
conveys vibrations from the engine to
the interior a diagram shows what faults
arise at what time and what might be
causing them that makes it a lot easier
for a repair shop to locate and fix
problems
ah four-e-and hi burger from service
technology says that as automotive
technology grows more complex his
department makes it possible to keep
this technology manageable so that
repair shops can clearly identify
analyze and solve problems in the future
with the advent of autonomous driving
cars will have even more sensors and
shufflers materials engineering
department watches over outtie cars and
their parts from development through
production to performance on the road
the team's work is divided into the
typical areas suspension engine interior
exterior just as you would intuitively
divide up a car from looking at the new
parts are all his department scrutinizes
they also look at old parts that fail to
do their jobs this is a focused ion beam
a combination of scanning electron
microscope and ion cannon that can
remove thin layers of material making it
possible to conduct high-resolution
analyses deep inside the part of teeth
removing outer layers exposes the spot
that needs to be examined functionally
important parts are growing ever smaller
explained shuffler we're reaching the
sub micro or nano meter range which is
really decisive for the functionality of
a component this technology reveals
damage and problems you wouldn't see
even with a magnifying glass an
essential field is semiconductor
technology this technology explains
specialist Robert Krause is central to
all automotive innovations coming in the
future
OD semiconductor lab ensures that the
technology fulfills the quality
standards that a maker of luxury cars
places on functionality thought so but
what exactly does that mean
and why is it important yeah things my
onion nd if you think of your cell phone
says cause if it's electronics stopped
working after 2 years you might get
annoyed but you'll probably say oh well
time to buy a new one but how DS
electronics are designed to work without
a hitch for 15 years and this is the
difference in lifespan and robustness
between consumer electronics and
automotive electronics this must
understand consumer and automotive
electronic the Audi team is especially
proud of what it calls the Meister Bock
it has several sections one is used to
examine the body of a new car design for
example robot arms scan the entire
vehicle and create a 3d image
even the tiniest and most inconspicuous
deviations are rendered visible and the
requirements facing the industry are
growing continuously
that inequality and at sim Amman from
Audi quality controls his quality
criteria are shifting with the
development of autonomous driving
alternative power trains and networking
inside the car and between the car and
its surroundings
howdy has to meet its customers changing
expectations aspects such as material
appearance and tolerances are also
subjected to meticulous examination if
something isn't up to standards
production processes are revised all
these measures aim to provide customers
with a high-quality vehicle with
engineering that functions perfectly
throughout the life of the car